ferien in fast ganz deutschland
wegfliegen in die sonne ans meer einfach
aus doch ausgerechnet jetzt ruft die
gewerkschaft verdi das flughafen
bodenpersonal zu streiks auf zu streiks
an den flughäfen zur sommerreisezeit
nichts geht mehr ja ein streik mitten in
der zeit in der das flughafen chaos
seinen absoluten höhepunkt erreicht hat
bilder wie diese vom hauptstadtflughafen
ber keine seltenheit sondern fast
mittlerweile schon der normalfall der
normalfall ein koffer chaos sie stapeln
sich wir sehen uns hier stehen herrenlos
in der abfertigungshalle wer in diesen
tagen mit einem koffer in den urlaub
will der kommt meist ohne ihn an bitte
jetzt
also streiks mitten in der urlaubszeit
das dürfte viele urlauber richtig sauer
machen 20.000 beschäftigte legen die
arbeit nieder von mittwochfrüh bis in
den donnerstag hinein das bedeutet
stillstand noch mehr chaos mitten in der
urlaubszeit ja und was machte der mann
der zu den streiks aufgerufen hat verdi
chef frank werneke ist erstmal im urlaub
ja sie haben tatsächlich richtig gehört
wernicke hat sich bereits in den urlaub
verabschiedet ein verdi sprecher
bestätigte bild werneke sei derzeit
nicht zu sprechen macht urlaub bis zum
12 august der verdi-chef versaut mit
seinem streik fielen die lang ersehnten
ferien genießt dann aber selbst den
urlaub wirklich unfassbar und bei allem
verständnis für das überlastete
bodenpersonal müssen die streiks
ausgerechnet in den ferien stattfinden
wo ohnehin schon alles chaotisch ist an
den flughäfen ja nach zwei jahren kohler
bedingt der urlaubs einschränkung haben
wir uns doch alle so sehr auf unseren
wohlverdienten urlaub gefreut
flughafen frankfurt 10 uhr morgens
warteschlangen und koffer berge so weit
das auge reicht flüge gestrichen die
menschen frustriert
der flughafen frankfurt ein sinnbild für
das deutsche reise disaster und inmitten
dieser urlaubs krise jetzt der nächste
glaubt die gewerkschaft verdi ruft zum
streik auf wir gehen davon aus dass dem
frankfurt und münchen zu starken
beeinträchtigungen vielen
flugannullierungen kommen wird wenn
nicht sogar der ganze luftverkehr der
lufthansa an dem tag zum erliegen kommt
20.000 beschäftigte des lufthansa
bodenpersonals sollen ihre arbeit
niederlegen und ein signal an den flug
gigant senden mehr gehalt mehr personal
weniger arbeit es ist das nächste
debakel an deutschen flughäfen seit
wochen dominieren diese bereits die
negativ schlagzeilen denn corona bedingt
wurde das flughafenpersonal zur
mangelware die folge gestrichene und
verpasste flüge genervte urlauber
deutschlandweit auch die fehlenden
gepäckabfertigung sorgen für bilder wie
diese vom flughafen in berlin unzählige
herrenlose koffer gepackt für den
sommerurlaub doch liegen gelassen am ber
die verantwortung hier bei den
angestellten der airlines nicht zuletzt
bei verdi bild weiß dass die gepäckstück
ihrem eigentümer ausgehändigt werden
kann bis kommendes jahr dauern nach zwei
jahren pandemie einem tobenden krieg in
europa und mega inflation wollen die
deutschen endlich ihren wohlverdienten
sommerurlaub antreten doch fehlendes
personal und jetzt wer die sorgen für
urlaubs fuß statt urlaubslust dann
einfach lieber bahn fahren oder
und besser nicht fäuste fliegen frauen
schreien und schubsen sich gegenseitig
aus einer regionalbahn die nachfrage
nach dem 9 euro ticket groß zu groß wie
der andrang auf den letzten zug vom
timmendorfer strand vom wochenende
belegt anstatt nordseeluft und
entspannung gibt eskalation im zug drei
polizeiwagen müssen anrücken nur so kann
der sitzplatz streit entschärft werden
auf bild anfrage weist die bahn jede
verantwortung von sich und für die
wenigen glücklichen die es doch noch zu
ihrem urlaubsziel schaffen heißt es füße
hoch und abschalten nicht auf der
kanarischen insel teneriffa
pünktlich zur eröffnung gibt es auch
hier chaos die urlauber drängen auf die
liegestühle schmeißen ihre handtücher
auf die beliebten plätze wer zu spät
kommt der bleibt ohne liege es scheint
ob liegestuhl sitzplatz in der
regionalbahn oder das flughafenpersonal
das angebot ist knapp die wohlverdiente
erholung muss man sich diesen sommer
hart erkämpfen der verdi streiks am
mittwochmorgen um 345 beginnen und bis
donnerstag um 6 uhr morgens dauern
wieviel lufthansa personal am streik
teil nimmt ist ungewiss doch eins ist
sicher dass flughafen chaos nimmt kein
ende
[Musik]
ja mittendrin ist unsere kollegin annika
rage jetzt am berliner flughafen annika
also morgen stillstand inwiefern merkt
man dieses chaos das für morgen
angekündigt ist denn jetzt schon wie es
aktuell die lage
ja sandra es wird natürlich der absolute
albtraum in der ferienzeit man muss sich
vorstellen die menschen haben jetzt noch
zwei jahren kommune wirklich die
möglichkeit mal wieder mit der familie
in den urlaub zu fahren dann darauf
lange gespart und jetzt eben dieser
streik das heißt es werden viele
menschen ihre flüge verpassen viele
flüge könnten eben auch
ausfallend und deshalb sind natürlich
die fluggäste auch ziemlich sauer es
handelt sich um 20.000 beschäftigte des
bodenpersonals der lufthansa dieser
streik soll morgen um 3 uhr 45 in der
nacht starten und dann bis donnerstag um
6 uhr gehen also mehr als 24 stunden wir
können hier einmal die lufthansa
schalter schauen er ist jetzt noch
ziemlich leer aber genau um diese
schalter geht es also die schalter und
die techniker werden dann morgen einfach
nicht mehr da sein und das heißt es kann
zu stillstand kommen zu absoluten chaos
und das alles weil eben das lufthansa
bodenpersonal mehr gehalt fordert das
ist natürlich verständnis
verständlich aber gerade eben in dieser
zeit in der alle in den urlaub fahren
wollen in dem die kinder ferien haben
und nach zwei jahren krone wieder in den
süden wollen ist das natürlich die
ungünstigste zeit und es trifft eben am
ende dieser streik vor allem die
passagiere
wir können jetzt hier noch einmal
schauen also es ist halt wie gesagt
beginn der sommerferien natürlich ist
hier einiges los wir waren eben auch an
der sicherheit die sicherheitskontrollen
sind voll das parkhaus ist voll es ist
natürlich auch sehr früh morgens aber es
wird natürlich jetzt immer mehr und das
merken wir jetzt auch in den letzten
minuten und wie es dann morgen wird das
bleibt abzuwarten annika welche rechte
habe ich dann als fluggast wenn mein
flug jetzt morgen betroffen ist entweder
von verspätungen oder vielleicht sogar
auch von einer annullierung
[Applaus]
genau als allererstes muss ich als
fluggast mich morgen natürlich erstmal
informieren ich kann mich auch bei der
lufthansa selbst informieren ob mein
flug überhaupt stattfindet und ab wann
der über abfliegt und dann ist es so bei
streikbedingten ausfällen oder
verspätungen bei mehr als drei stunden
muss mir die airline einen neuen flug
zur verfügung stellen meinen flug
umbuchen bei mehr als fünf stunden
bekomme ich geld zurück und in diesem
fall können die fluggäste der morgigen
flüge sogar auf eine entschädigung
hoffen das ist natürlich nur ja
sozusagen ein kleines stückchen hoffnung
aber man möchte sich nicht vorstellen
dass man hier mit seinen 23 kindern
morgen an kommt eigentlich in den
sommerurlaub frieden muss und der dann
gecancelt wird das war wirklich nicht
schön besten dank für diese eindrücke
vom br live für uns vor ort ankam
[Musik]